[Music]
hey you guys welcome to tomes of terror
my book review show
now the one that i'm talking about today
again i'm doing some more stuff with
kindle unlimited now this is an author
that i had been meaning to get into for
a while just because it seems like her
stuff is like everywhere
so uh this is darcy coates i don't know
a great deal about her she i know she's
australian
and she's kind of like
she seems to be sort of like the queen
of the haunted house uh genre you know
what i mean it seems like a lot of her
books are haunted house books and when
you go through on goodreads or amazon or
whatever like um almost all of them
because she's written a lot
are really really highly rated
and another interesting thing too is
that all of her books most or all of
them are actually available to read for
free if you have kindle unlimited so she
was definitely an author that i wanted
to get around to just because so many
people talked about her so many people
had read her books and she'd read so
many and she'd written so many rather
that i was like well you know i'll get
into that at some point and that point
has arrived
now the one i chose um i just kind of
just chose this one at random i guess it
was just because it was the one that
kept popping up because i guess it's the
newest one uh this is called the
haunting of lee harker and apparently
this came out in october of 2021 i think
she actually had a couple books that
came out that same month or right around
that same time period but i don't so i
don't know if she's done any since then
but this one kept getting recommended so
i assumed this was the newest one or
among the newest ones and again this is
kind of like a haunted house story but
kind of a little bit different now from
what i could determine this is the first
uh darcy coates book that i've read
now i read some other reviews of it and
one thing that a lot of people said was
this was different than what she usually
wrote
uh not different in genre because
they're still haunted house stories but
maybe different in
tone or different in style so i can't
really speak to that because this is the
first book of hers that i've read it
seemed like some people
most people really really dug this book
and i actually really dug it as well uh
which i'll get into in a minute but
it seemed like people either really
liked it or there were like some reviews
on it that liked a lot of her other
stuff and then i was like yeah i just
this one wasn't for me uh so i don't
know how different it actually is uh
than her regular stuff one reviewer that
i saw said that a lot of her haunted
house books while really
cool and enjoyable and stuff i believe
the word she used was cozy
um but she said this one's different
because this one's actually like really
really scary so i'm assuming that
maybe her other stuff was more kind of
like again like a cozy haunted house
story whereas this one is kind of more
scary this actually was a pretty creepy
uh book just the descriptions of the
things in it were actually really good
like if you pictured them in your head
like if i pictured this being made into
a movie i was like yeah that would
probably be really scary like the
imagery that she describes in it
so the story of this um we're following
the protagonist lee harker it's all from
her point of view and it's all in the
present tense which usually bothers me
but i got used to it after a couple of
pages and it didn't really register
anymore
now one thing i will say
at no point was i going to dnf this
um but i will say that
uh the first
i don't know it's maybe the first third
of the book maybe not quite that much
i was kind of like
not really knowing where this was going
and i was almost kind of like it was
getting almost to a point where i was
just kind of like okay can we like get
on with it or it was like a little bit
repetitive
but then
this real big twist or i don't know if
it's a twist but like a big reveal
happens and then at that point the story
doesn't become like a different
almost becomes like a different type of
story it almost kind of turns more into
a creepy mystery and i was way on board
after that like after the you know after
this initial part where i was just like
i'm not really sure because i was like
i'm not really sure if i'm digging this
because it's just kind of it seemed like
a lot of the same thing
and i wasn't really sure
you know where it was going like what
direction it was going in but once that
reveal happened and it's not
this is a really really hard book to
talk about without
spoiling it and i really didn't want to
spoil it because it's new but
i mean as i go on i might like actually
just say hey spoilers and
see what happens because it's really
really difficult to talk about if you
don't spoil it
so
pretty much the first page of this book
starts out with a bang it starts out
with a haunting so lee harker is this
woman
she lives in this uh
very large rambling house
um i don't really know i never got a
sense of how
old she was i kind of thought maybe
she was maybe in her 40s maybe 30s 40s
something like that she seems to be very
um introverted she seems to be very like
set in her ways she kind of likes being
alone she likes routine
and she loves this house she's actually
lived in this house for 15 years and
she's always lived there alone
and she has a job as she works like at a
museum she's like some kind of archivist
or you know art restore or something
like that and uh you know or some kind
of like museum thing and it's a job that
she likes very much and she basically
just has a routine she gets up and she
does the same thing every day and she
goes to her job and comes home into her
house which is as i said it's kind of
like an old rambling i think it's like
five bedrooms she says at some point but
she loves it it's like her sanctuary
but for whatever reason oh another thing
i was gonna say too is that she seems to
be she seems to be one of those people
that's like really isolated but doesn't
really seem all that bothered by that
like she doesn't seem like oh i wish i
had more friends or i wish i had this
and that and the other shin she seems
quite content uh being alone it's
it's not real clear if she actually is
or if she's just like telling herself
i'm not really sure but i mean she
doesn't really seem all that upset about
it
but um the only family she appears to
have is a sister named meg
and she and meg are estranged
and
it seems like uh you know you don't
really know the reasons for it but
the implication being that the reasons
are kind of dumb or you know it's so
it's just kind of but there was like a
rift between them and that kind of like
plays into stuff later on
so pretty much from the beginning like
you only find this stuff out like later
on like as it goes through but the the
book starts out as i said she's lived in
this house for 15 years she loves this
house she's never had any trouble with
it before
but then all of a sudden
um at night she starts hearing
weird [ __ ] like it's usually like
emanating from this little cabinet or
this little closet or storage space
that's like under the stairs
and she's like it's interesting because
i've never been able to get into
this storage space because it's always
been locked and she's like so i never
really
used it or needed it and so she just
kind of like forgot it existed pretty
much um you know it's just kind of
become part of the part of the
background
so she kind of hears stuff like the door
knob rattling down there and she starts
to see what she initially just calls a
something now as uh you know as the
first third of the book goes on and
she's describing uh in real time
what the haunting is like like what this
thing looks like and how it comes every
night and all of the things like she has
to end up hiding from it at one point
she calls the police and they come there
and obviously they don't find anything
and but she kind of describes it as this
being that looks that's like really
really tall
and has kind of like really long
scraggly hair and just has these really
round
like perfectly round like shiny eyes
like almost like an owl but
without any pupils or anything like that
so it's this really really creepy kind
of thing and like i said you know some
nights it seems like it's like
escalating so this something this being
kind of comes to her house every night
so she's kind of
doing her routine still going to work
and doing her job but then she's almost
kind of starting to like dread coming
home and it's really upsetting her
because this is a house that she loved
and you know she's terrified but you
know uh by
and but she also doesn't want to leave
the house because she loves it
and
so for the first third of the book it
kind of goes on like that like i said so
it's basically just know that going in
the i think it's about the first third
but it's basically in present tense
she's just talking about
this escalating haunting in essentially
real time like she's just like and this
night
you know this happened and i had you
know ended up like in the you know
hiding in the closet while this thing
was like nails were coming underneath
and like all that kind of stuff and it's
really spooky i will say that but like
after a while i was just kind of like
okay but i don't really know where this
is going and i was like is the whole
book like this just a real time you know
kind of like uh you know
description of a haunting and i said i'm
not really sure if i'm like i said i
wasn't gonna put it down because it's
you know i i saw that there was a lot of
the book left so i said well i'm sure
this is probably like leading up to
something and indeed it does
now again if you want to read this it's
very new
you know it just came out a few months
ago i will say okay
as i said this is really hard to talk
about without spoiling it so spoiler
alert spoiler alert spoiler alert if you
want to read this book please turn this
video off right now
and go read it as if you have kindle
unlimited you can read it for free
because i'm just about to spoil because
i'm not going to spoil the whole thing
i'm not just like the end or anything
but the i'll spoil the reveal that
happens
about one third of the way in that sends
the story off in a different direction
um just so you know that the whole book
isn't like the first third it kind of
goes in a different direction after that
so again spoiler alert last warning
so about a third of the way into the
book uh you find and i actually kind of
suspected that this reveal was gonna
happen um you know if you've watched any
kind of horror in the last 20 30 years
um you might be able to see it coming i
mean i did kind of start to suspect it
after a while uh so i kind of guessed
so it wasn't like as big but it's not
the only twist you know what i mean so
it's not really that big a deal if you
guess
so again spoiler alert again last last
warning this time
but uh yeah so it turns out
that lee
uh is actually
a ghost that she's actually dead
so at that point uh you find out that
this being that she's been seeing in her
house
is actually the elderly woman who moved
into the house after she disappeared
so after this reveal it turns out that
the elderly woman whose name is sarah
can actually see lee uh because she's
you know she has a gift like for seeing
ghosts or whatever she can see her and
she can communicate with her
and basically she's like yeah i
suspected as soon as i moved in here
that there was somebody in here and then
so she's like you kind of go in and out
and the reason that lee was seeing sarah
as a monster essentially is because one
she didn't know she was dead
and two she didn't know you know she
didn't know who this thing was so she
just made it into this nightmarish
because she also has these other kind of
like nightmarish things happen in the
beginning of the book like she goes out
to the shed and it seems like all the
implements are coming and like trying to
stab her and things like that so she has
these kind of like weird fugues but you
find out later like after the reveal
that she's been dead the whole time
that um she was just seeing things that
way because that's how she was
perceiving them because she didn't know
she was dead so from that point onward
like the final two-thirds of the book
is essentially like a mystery story
where sarah and the ghost of lee
are trying to figure out how lee died
because she doesn't remember
so it kind of goes into this thing where
it's like well you know we have to pin
down like when i was killed and you know
one thing that sarah does say to her is
like pretty sure that you were murdered
but she will never tell lee
what she looks like to her because like
i said you know lee the ghost when she
looked at sarah like for a long time she
saw essentially like a monster like a
big creepy scary like thing with these
big round eyes which turned out to be
just like round spectacles
but as as her expectations changed she
started to see her she really was now
lee if she looks at herself in a mirror
she can still like perceive things like
a living person she perceives that she's
moving things and stuff like that
because that's
her expectation because she's kind of in
this weird limbo but
um in the real world she can't usually
move things she's only perceiving that
she moves things
so uh so if she looks at herself in the
mirror she still sees herself as she was
when she was alive but when sarah looks
at her
she sees she won't tell her because she
doesn't want to upset her i guess but
she's like yeah pretty sure you were
murdered so you're led to assume that
she probably looks pretty [ __ ] up from
that point on the rest of the story is
basically the two of them because lee
can't really
leave the house
she kind of goes
into like weird limbos every now and
then where she loses like a couple weeks
at a time um you know so
she has to essentially use sarah
you know sarah has to go to like for
example lee's job and say you know when
was the last time she was here so they
can kind of pinpoint where it was she
went and like what happened to her and
stuff like that so after so after that
point it got like really really
interesting so i will say that the first
third of it was a little bit it's good
it's creepy like it's very descriptive
like of this uh you know lee describing
this haunting that's happening to her
like in real time it's really creepy but
i thought it was starting to go on a
little bit too long and then i was just
kind of sitting there going well where
where are we going with this but then
when you get the reveal
and then you determine that now from
this point forward it's going to be a
mystery story about how lee died
i was kind of like okay i'm totally on
board with that so just know that going
in like i said now obviously i spoiled
the big reveal so you shouldn't have
been listening to this if you still
wanted to read it so that's on you
that's your fault i warned you like
three or four times so don't so don't
come at me but uh but yeah so overall
for like the first darcy codes book that
i've read even though as i said i've
heard that it's different from her other
ones but i will definitely be reading
more of her because she is a really i
mean her writing is really really good
and really descriptive you really get a
good
sense of
what's going on
she's very good at kind of like painting
a picture in your mind and i really
actually liked the uh the characters of
lee and sarah very much i kind of feel
like even though the story is from lee's
point of view i don't know if she was
quite as well developed a character as
sarah was but i guess that's just
because you know lee was a ghost and so
she was kind of like and she hadn't had
a real exciting life prior to that which
was another kind of thing that i guess
that was another kind of like point of
discussion in the book and something
that i found really interesting was that
you know she
had essentially like disappeared and you
know there had been an investigation and
stuff like that but it seemed like
nobody really
cared all that much you know to me
because nobody really knew her because
she was so
not isolated but she just kept to
herself and she seemed to be perfectly
happy doing that so it's kind of like
her neighbors didn't really know like
you know her co-workers were like they
didn't even when she didn't show up back
uh to work after the christmas break
they were just kind of like oh we just
thought she quit we didn't really think
about it like nobody called her um and
again the only family member she had was
meg her sister and they hadn't spoken to
one another for a long time so meg does
actually come into the story like a
little bit later on um you know to sort
of like figure out so she did actually
care but i mean she's been missing for
uh i think it's like a year or something
like that or almost a year and you know
the police were just kind of like hey we
looked around we looked in the house
there was no sign of foul play you know
we investigated a few people but there
weren't really any leads nobody really
seemed to know
you know and there were kind of things
that hinted that maybe she might have
left
on purpose
which she was just kind of like well
that doesn't sound like something i
would do you know what i mean because
i'm i was happy in my house i was happy
at my job i you know i was kind of had
all my [ __ ] together and
she's like i wouldn't just disappear
unless there was a reason so
you know that so as all the tendrils
kind of uh you know come to play out
it's just it was really good so it was
like a really riveting book like from
the two-thirds point like you know from
after a third like after the haunting
part is described then it becomes kind
of like a mystery story and i was really
on board with that so yeah i'll
definitely be reading some more of her
stuff because i really really liked this
one a lot as i said it was a haunted
house story but
with kind of a twist to it and honestly
even like toward the end like the
friendship between the two women
you know the dead one and the live one
uh was actually really
touching you know i mean it was like
actually like a really heartbreaking
uh you know there was like a lot of
really good like really
heartwarming stuff in there uh so which
which is crazy so because i did actually
you know sarah was actually like a
really good character she was like an 80
something year old woman and who also
lived alone and really likes this big
house and her uh
her thing kind of ties in with the house
as well like her past also kind of ties
into the house so everything is kind of
like tied in very nicely but yeah so
this was like a really good book really
i mean i read it in probably two
sittings uh so it didn't really take me
very long to read it at all maybe just
like a couple of hours even though it's
i don't know it was 350 pages something
like that if you if you start reading it
and you're just kind of like oh this is
like kind of boring or it's not going
anywhere just like hang tight because it
does actually go off in a different
direction now as i said some people that
liked some of darth darcy coates other
stuff didn't really care for this one
one of the main criticisms i saw was
that they thought the character of lee
like did some dumb [ __ ] that like a
person wouldn't do i didn't really get
that impression um i can kind of see
what they're talking about but it didn't
really
read that didn't really register to me
that she was being stupid or anything
like that and a lot of the stuff that
makes her seem stupid or whatever in the
first part of the book is kind of
explained later so it didn't really
bother me uh and you know to be honest
like most horror has people doing
stupid stuff i mean to be to be fair or
otherwise we wouldn't have any horror
because if everybody just kind of stayed
where they were and never did anything
never went to investigate that scary
basement uh we'd never have any horror
movies so you know i'm not gonna get
like too uh upset about it but yeah so
if you have kindle unlimited uh you can
read this for free if you've read any
other darcy coates books and are looking
forward to reading this one uh let me
know let me know if you read this one
what you thought of it
and uh that'll do it for this tomes of
terror book review i will see you guys
on the next one
bye